[Musica]
e per dire che la mia velocità va un po
come un allegro vivacissimo opera 35
concerto in re maggiore ciajkovskij ciao
mi presento mi chiamo francesca sono una
giornalista lavoro a sky tg24
sono molto emozionata son talmente
emozionata che è già partita la foto
sono emozionato perché non sono abituato
a parlare di me stessa sono abituata a
parlare con le altre persone a
raccontare le altre persone e quindi è
sempre difficile no mettersi davanti a
tutti a raccontare quello che uno sente
e come svolge il proprio lavoro
quindi quando sono stata invitata rimini
ho subito pensato tema altra velocità
ho pensato alle mie mattine di confine
cioè le mattine in cui esco di casa
intorno alle 3 un quarto per essere alle
4 in redazione perché la rassegna stampa
e all mio ritmo non salgo sullo scooter
io vivendo a milano uso lo scooter sotto
il freddo la pioggia o i miei pensieri
vanno velocissimi io va dai 50 ai
semafori non funzionano a di notte come
dire tanto siete a casa a dormire
e invece siamo fuori ci sono io gli
spazzini ci sono gli universitari che
bevono l'ultimo bicchiere quelli che
partono quelli che tornano siamo in
tanti
io viaggio i 50 e penso due cose la
prima è che tutte le persone che amo
solo nel luogo più sicuro del mondo a
letto e questo è un momento magico per
me quando non ho sempre l'alba però
quando ci penso proprio a questa cosa
qua da sempre da quando ho iniziato
questo mestiere e la seconda è che mi
pagano per andare a fare una delle cose
che mi piace di più cioè leggere i
giornali e provare a raccontarli come
meglio sono in grado di fare io non
racconto la verità racconto i fatti chi
cosa dove quando e perché
14 agosto 2018 11 37 per la precisione
crolla un ponte
per intenderci quel ponte autostradale
che va da genova ovest all'aereporto
ponte morandi è un fatto quel giorno
pioveva tantissimo tantissimi simo una
cosa mai vista
io non lo so questa è una percezione
quindi si avvicina alle tante verità
c'era chi diceva così c'era chi diceva
che in effetti non aveva mai visto così
tanta pioggia e non solo momento più più
ancora degli alluvioni che abbiamo
vissuto a genova nel 2011 nel 2015 è
comunque una verità tante pioveva c'è un
fatto e pioveva la verità rimane
comunque la più grande ambizione che
abbiamo come come giornalisti allora
ricominciamo faccio un passo indietro e
vi dico che la verità così come l'amore
per questo lavoro
me l'ha insegnato a questa bambina
questa bambina ragazzina perché ormai
aveva 16 anni di francoforte che voleva
diventare una giornalista lei voleva
diventare cronista a raccontare la
verità al mondo intero
e intanto io da solo nella mia stanza
avevo otto anni la raccontava me quindi
io ho vissuto tutto quello che ha
vissuto lei lei mi ha insegnato la
verità
l'ingiustizia che cosa vuol dire essere
di una razza rispetto a un'altra
ma insegnato racconto mi ha insegnato
che litigare in famiglia
serve e allo stesso tempo pensando ad
anna ancora oggi mi capita di per lavoro
di leggere altre notizie che mi
riconducono che mi riconducono a lei ed
è partita è partita all'inizio questa
fotografia quindi non può essere una
sorpresa
attualmente mi sono domandata masse anna
frank avesse avuto twitter sarebbero
andate diverse le cose c'è tutto poteva
essere diverso ma per anna dentro la sua
stanzetta all'interno di questo alloggio
segreto sarebbe andata diversamente
io questo non posso rispondere però per
bana è andata a diversi
la mente ban ha sette anni e vive in
siria e il tweet parla chiaro diceva
buon pomeriggio d'aleppo
leggo per dimenticare la guerra sopra la
sua testa cadevano le bombe in siria
negli ultimi sette anni causa guerra
sono molto sono morte oltre 350 mila
persone
tutto passa un po inosservato ai nostri
occhi non credo che sia la notizia che
per prima leggete quando vi svegliate
alla mattina no
eppure tra le tante notizie e non credo
che esista soltanto bana nel mondo e ci
saranno altre ban e nel mondo
questa non è passata inosservata lei ha
scritto a trump ha scritto ai vari
presidenti del mondo
vabbè non è passata inosservata live
even turchia adesso con i suoi
fratellini la stampa americana ha detto
una cosa ha detto una bambina che twitta
di aver paura della guerra non può
passare inosservata e così è stato
tant'è vero che bana è una delle persone
più influenti del nostro pianeta
detto questo ha senso arrivare per primi
no perché per il nostro mestiere ha
sempre avuto un senso arrivare per primi
dare il buco a qualcun altro che in
gergo è avere una notizia rispetto ai
colleghi
secondo me no secondo me oggi nel 2018
l'importante è esserci e raccontarlo
meglio però quando penso a prima
penso a oriana fallaci penso a 51 anni
fa quando nel 67 essere donna e avere
soltanto colleghi uomini ed essere in
guerra in vietnam fa la differenza
arrivare prima e lei arrivava per prima
non sempre però è arrivata per prima
generale giap per esempio per oggi no
oggi non fa la differenza
la cittá torriana perché
è un esempio calzante di quanto di
quanto contasse non mi ha sempre dato
l'impressione di essere una giornalista
che non ha mai avuto paura di nulla no
cioè al di là di quelle che sono le
vostre posizioni come il giornalista
come scrittrice arrivava prima al suo
aspetto prima le sue fotografie prima
prima ancora di un carattere che poi
abbiamo scoperto una donna piena di
emozioni no è stata caratterizzata e
caratterizzante in questo era una che le
viveva e le comunicava fino alla fine
comunque sotto il casco le treccine il
suo eyeliner perfetto e un orologio
firmatissimo che la teneva attaccata
alla vita che avrebbe ripreso quando
sarebbe ripartita dal vietnam ha verso
l'italia verso milano mentre altri
colleghi camilla cederna per esempio
altra firma dell'europeo raccontava come
cambiano i costumi bene le cose sono
cambiate
e allora mi domando ma se anna frasi
scusate se oriana fallaci avesse avuto
twitter
secondo voi avrebbe usato non lo so non
sono anche questo però io credo che
essendo una donna sempre stata piena
carica di emozioni qualcosa le avrebbe
suscitato c'è il politico che lei ha
sempre attaccato perché adesso sono in
pochi giornalisti no lei era una delle
poche voci
credo che qualcosa trump per esempio ne
avrebbe suscitato e quindi parlo di
emozioni
parlo di emozioni per dire che non
esiste la cultura dell'emozione non
esiste in italia non esiste in europa
non esiste nel mondo non esiste un corso
che ci insegni come dobbiamo reagire di
fronte alle cose noi aspettiamo la vita
anzi facciamo così
noi aspettiamo di innamorarci così le
proviamo tutte in una sola volta non
siamo preparati andiamo a tentativi e
parlo di emozioni perché fra poco
parlerò di simulazione
però prima c'è questo io potevo arrivare
a rimini senza portarvi una notizia è
questa la cosa per cui nel mio piccolo
solo capace a fare allora se non esiste
sui social sui social e in televisione
sui giornali questa cosa non è mai
accaduto
è vero e falso io uso twitter per
esempio per fare informazione uso uso
instagram per divertirmi sono fotografie
si racconta un lavoro ma realtà è più
per ridere e uso facebook come se fosse
un barrio entro beve un caffè sento un
po i commenti riguardo le partite e non
commento niente me ne vado
lascio così dunque mi ha fatto molto
riflettere
marta bisogni in questa ex ormai
youtuber che decide di andarsene lei
saluta i suoi milioni di follower
dicendo vado voglio fare l'influenza di
me stesso cioè lascia sospesa una
domanda che faccio più rumore se resto o
somme ne vado potrebbe diventare un
lusso tutto ciò lo è nel momento in cui
si decidesse di cambiare rotta con
estrema velocità visto che stiamo
andando una velocità molto sostenuta le
cose cambiano più in fretta rispetto a
prima
bene torno indietro di una settimana
quasi una settimana perché la domenica
derby di milano inter milan
improvvisamente verso san siro si
avvicina una macchina blindata
dentro questa macchina c'è una delle più
grandi rock star del mondo una delle più
grandi rockstar tra l'altro più
riconoscibile al mondo e dice una cosa
prima di scendere dalla macchina
nessuno vi dovrà fotografare non voglio
telecamere vicino a me non voglio
fotografi non voglio nessuno qualcuno si
è accorto che c'era nessuno è riuscito a
fotografarlo
eppure la partita l'ha vista e noi non
gli diremo che una foto c'è mick jagger
allo stadio a san siro a vedere la
partita
non posso dirgli dove ho trovato questa
fotografia comunque stiamo veramente
pochissimi a saperlo perché è stata
rimossa subito però c'era e io ho dovuto
portare di questa foto
perché se no voi non avreste creduto
perché siamo nell'epoca delle immagini
siamo nell'epoca in cui voi mettete più
in discussione quello che vi racconta un
giornalista o chiunque altro
risp
quanto si faceva prima e dunque io ho
parlato di di emozioni domandandomi
anche se stiamo andando in questa
direzione la direzione del sparire non
apparire e lo sa magari magari perché
lui una rockstar e può farlo
sarei curiosa di vedere se ci
riuscirebbe un politico ho parlato di
emozioni perché questo è il tema che ci
rende superiori alla tecnologia ai robot
al futuro che può anche essere oscuro
perché la tecnologia ci salva e avete
visto che banane un esempio se non ci
fosse stato twitter forse non sarebbe
andata così no sarebbe diventata come
tutti quei bambini che muoiono sotto le
bombe sono tantissimi
anche in questo momento però ci sono
anche degli aspetti oscuri e noi li
possiamo superare nel momento in cui
facciamo un corso di emotività cioè la
smettiamo di andare per tentativi
iniziamo a dare un nome alle emozioni la
smettiamo di confondere attrazione per
amore frustrazione per rabbia
iniziamo a dargli i nomi anche perché mi
sono resa conto in questo periodo
storico che spesso riusciamo a sentirci
umani e riusciamo a fare aggregazione
nel momento in cui c'è una catastrofe
c'è una guerra in corso però da noi c'è
un terremoto
crolla al ponte di genova allora lì sì
diventiamo tutti umani improvvisamente
no rispetto invece a quanto facciamo sui
social soprattutto sotto falso nome
lì siamo un'aggregazione non ci siamo
mai visti
non ci siamo mai conosciuti eppure siamo
un gruppo fortissimo
allora ho letto questa intervista
qualche giorno fa a questo
neuroscienziato lui è un professore
all'università di osaka e dice io adesso
tra qualche tempo vi porterò dei robot
che si emozioneranno cioè lui sta
inventando il robot che riuscirà a
piangere riuscirà a ridere e per me
rimane una simulazione
mi è venuto in mente a si muove il suo
racconto che si chiama bugiardo racconto
del 69 fantascienza ma siamo nel 2018
se lui potesse
essere qui a rimini con noi direbbe le
cose si stanno avverando
va beh lui insegue il mito delle tre
leggi della robotica no le ha inventate
lui quindi un robot o non deve fare male
all'essere umano
peccato però che in questo racconto
venga fuori questo robot difettoso no
perchè questo robot non era nato per
leggere nella testa delle persone eppure
succede ma lui proprio per non andare
contro a questa prima legge che dice non
fare male a chi ha vicino a te non dirà
la verità per non ferire di conferire
perché io sono manama per non andare
contro questa legge per non ferire gli
scienziati che ha di fronte no che
l'hanno inventato con un difetto perché
capisce leggendo nel loro pensiero che
potrebbe fargli del male
simo la ri non sa che cosa vuol dire far
del male no poi però incontra un altro
dei protagonisti che si accorge che lui
mente perché lei gli chiede innamorata
di un collega ma lo è mi ama e lo invia
e quindi dai urla bugiardo e lui implode
muore che io li ho anche pensato ma
poverino
ma perché perché sono umana problema che
lui stava simulando e dunque per
ricollegarmi al neuroscienziato vi parlo
di fabio fabio primo robot assunto a
tempo determinato
siamo a edimburgo è l'anno scorso fabio
licenziato ma subito in tronco perché
fabio ha dentro questo supermercato non
riusciva a convincere le persone ad
assaggiare dei prodotti e quindi c'è
pure la parte del impacciato licenziate
no c'è roba che se fosse andato bene
molti dei suoi colleghi sarebbero stati
licenziati
allora che cosa succede qualcuno tira il
fiato alcun altro piange è la verità
cioè ha pianto perché fabio è stato
licenziato simulazione andiamo avanti
per simulazioni noi che non ci vogliamo
ad entrare no nelle emozioni nei
sentimenti ci fanno paura poi finisce
male pure queste ci salveranno
soprattutto l'empatia
dico che non possono rubarci le lacrime
possono inventare quello che vogliono ma
non potranno rubarci le lacrime perché
le lacrime ci rendono superiori e quindi
vi racconto che tipo di lacrime ho
vissuto ho visto e non ho voluto
raccontare a genova
io sono di genova ma questo non ha
affatto dei racconti che ho trovato
qualcosa in più qualcosa in meno per
intenderci ovunque mi avesse mandato la
redazione nel giorno in cui accade un
fatto avrei provato a raccontarlo per
come sono capace no però i genovesi li
conosco e sono un popolo di che
sottolineano molto la dignità perché non
piangono in pubblico è un esempio che
deve essere preso a grandi linee hanno
modo di utilizzare il silenzio che è un
silenzio molto rumoroso fa tanto rumore
quindi quando mi hanno inviato a genova
il giorno dopo il 15 di agosto dopo la
rassegna e ho cercato la bellezza che mi
ha insegnato anna frank cioè mi sono
detta che la disperazione la potevate
immaginare
basta immedesimarsi no cosa che un robot
e non riuscirà mai a fare ma basta
immaginare che cosa voglia dire quando
muoiono 43 persone in un giorno in cui
in tanti sono rimasti a casa perché
questo succede a genova quando c'è
un'allerta tipo in questo momento c'è un
allerta arancione
noi sappiamo che è meglio non muoverci
questo perché sono morte tante persone
durante questi anni dall'alluvione del
2010 ma prima ci sono state altre cose
quindi 10 la 11 il 15 noi stiamo a casa
chiudono le scuole non andiamo a
lavorare
io non sono tornato a casa quel giorno
ero avevo un giorno libero
e non sono tornata sono rimasti a milano
lascio un punto interrogativo comunque
decido che andando alla ricerca di
queste storie io devo trovare delle
storie che fermino tutto perché in quel
momento si sta andando velocissimi no
verso una verità che non sappiamo verso
il numero delle persone che hanno perso
la vita non lo sapevamo
pensate soltanto che è successo di
martedì i funerali di stato sono stati
domenica quello stesso giorno sia
trovata
l'ultima delle vittime che si chiama
mirko quindi provo a cercare delle
storie che possano dare della speranza
la prima è questa si chiama federico
federico da subito si è preso le ferie
lui lavora in una sla quarto si è preso
le ferie e che cosa ha fatto è andato da
tutti i fornai a comprare focaccia ea
portarla nel campo dove dove i vigili
del fuoco che senza stop veramente
continuava a lavorare perché c'era la
ricerca delle persone sotto le macerie
perché c'erano le famiglie che stavano
arrivando perché c'era un via vai tra
vigili del fuoco protezione civile
ma se lui ne è derivato questo per i
giorni fino all'ultimo giorno questi
sono più o meno 50 kg di focaccia
il singolo e questa è una storia che
andava raccontata
e poi c'è un altro la storia di giulia
che aspetta pietro pietro è nato il 14
settembre al 23 59 pietro aspettate un
mese praticamente per nascere quel
giorno
suo padre gianluca che nelle tele
fotografia si trova sul ponte che cade
cade con la macchina insieme a un
collega
quel giorno gianluca guida valutano
guida mi ha raccontato che lui non ama
tanto
la paura le cose eppure in un giorno di
allerta quando non doveva lavorare ma
lavora ugualmente perché trasportava
mobili guida il suo collega non c'è più
gianluca si salva si salva con una
parola e dovere pietro nascere perché
poi è vero che ci sono i vigili del
fuoco ma lui rimasto un po appeso la
macchina cinture e lui ha avuto un solo
pensiero e questo pensiero urlava io
devo vedere nascere pietro e così è
andata
e poi c'è vittorio è vittorio anche era
sul ponte però era più o meno a 50 metri
prima del collasso
venendo da genova ovest stava andando
verso l'aeroporto verso ponente quindi
un certo punto non si rende bene conto
che cosa sta succedendo però vede che
davanti a lui inchiodano lui scende e
salva le altre persone perché in quel
momento li stavano arrivando
motociclisti di tutto persone che
ovviamente non vivono allerta come la
vediamo noi ma pensate siamo alla
vigilia del 15 d'agosto le persone vanno
a prendere i traghetti vanno in vacanza
e lui quel quel che ha potuto affermato
e ha salvato la vita queste persone
qui lo vediamo e siamo esattamente nel
campo che che vi dicevo no dove federico
ha portato la focaccia perché il giorno
del crollo del ponte vittorio
trasportava frutta e verdura lavora al
mercato di bolzaneto
cosa che ha continuato a fare dal giorno
dopo
solo che non l'ha più fatto per portare
la frutta e verdura i negozi l'ha fatto
per portare frutta e verdura gratis a
questo campo e ha pianto ha pianto nel
momento in cui abbiamo iniziato a
parlare ed è un umorismo un po genovese
dirvi che a un certo punto abbiamo
sorriso perchè gli ho detto ma guitar ma
proprio adesso
ma c'è con tutti i momenti che c'erano
perché è andato avanti perché questo era
il suo moto c'è la velocità era quella
di non fermarsi se si fosse fermato cosa
che ha fatto per qualche minuto e che di
certo io
non perché deve essere privato ma perché
era un momento nostro cioè ci sono cose
che devono rimanere però ve lo racconto
perché si è fermato ha pianto e forse in
quel momento si è scrollato di dosso il
senso di colpa che ancora si porta
addosso si porta dentro nell'essere vivo
rispetto ai bambini che oggi non ci sono
e che sono rimasti sotto le macerie
andiamo veloci andiamo molto veloce e
quando mi hanno invitata qui ho pensato
dove stiamo andando e uso
l'immaginazione no non lo so dove stiamo
andando però so che il giornalismo sta
andando nella direzione del del menù da
ristorante cioè oggi noi possiamo
scegliere cosa mangiare dove e da tutto
il mondo in una via no stiamo andando
verso questo tipo di giornalismo
non che prima i giornali di settore non
esistessero anzi esistevano no però
c'era quell'informazione che decideva le
notizie sulla notiziabilità si basa
sulle tre esse non c'è che cosa conta
raccontare quali sono le notizie che
davvero possono interessare si sta un po
stravolgendo questo concetto perché
adesso sembra che le persone siano
interessati a tutto no possono
informarsi con tutto e io dico che noi
informazione dobbiamo alzare l'asticella
ci stiamo provando però la siamo anche
nel momento in cui il lettore la smette
di pensare che non debba pagare per
questa qualità perché tutto ciò che non
è a pagamento fa del lettore un prodotto
il prodotto non è quello che state
leggendo quello che state guardando il
prodotto siete voi
quindi noi alziamo l'asticella in un
giornalismo che cambia e credo che
hashtag 24 che la trasmissione di
riccardo bocca va in onda venerdì sera
possa in qualche modo dimostrarlo perché
decidiamo i temi sulla base di un gruppo
facebook in cui le persone chiunque si
può iscrivere in cui le persone
propongono sulla base dei problemi che
ritiene reali
non il problema sotto casa i problemi
che ritiene reali e noi ascoltiamo e
disegniamo la trasmissione sulla base
delle loro preoccupazioni sulla base di
quello che per loro conta e poi
interagiscono stiamo andando verso
questo con creatività con passione e con
l'empatia che tutto ciò che si salverà
secondo me vi racconto il giorno in cui
è cambiata la mia velocità anche se
suona un po come tschaikowsky e perché
un po a milano è un po perché io sono
così e soprattutto se questi sono gli
orari se entro le 4 del mattino per per
leggere i giornali e fare una rassegna è
chiaro che non possa avere un suono la
musica domestica il tempo in questo non
può avere un suono lento oppure adagio
ha un suono allegro e vivacissimo la mia
velocità cambia il 23 luglio del 2016
il 23 luglio del 2016 al giorno del mio
compleanno e muore deltizia le viti io
non posso raccontarvi perché cambia la
mia velocità perché del tutto personale
ma non è detto che non possa cambiare
anche la vostra
siamo in onda mi ascoltate
accidenti non avrei voluto pensavo di
farcela come tante altre volte invece la
vita non la decidiamo noi
volevo salutarvi con questo messaggio
ringraziarvi e lasciarvi anche così un
po di me salutati perché è nata così e
mentone rotoli da tanto tempo non ci
sono e mi siete mancati molto il lavoro
mi è mancato molto del lavoro per me è
stato una fonte di vita il lavoro e
verità il nostro lavoro e verità deve
essere verità adamo un debito verso i
telespettatori
dobbiamo non accontentarvi devo dire la
verità ma spesso anche di pensare che
bella questa vita fino alla fine hanno
apprezzato
ho pregato perché stessi qui con i miei
bambini come marito con la mia mamma con
il mio mondo ma non sono arrabbiata o
ognuno di noi ha un destino a un
percorso il mio cerchio si viene e dove
va a chiudersi così però va ricordato
che queste parole sono importanti perché
se al tema della vita come persone si
accorge deve sbagliato di un aver fatto
quello che arriva desiderato voluto
la cosa è una granata io credo che una
malattia e poi l'esito di questa
malattia sia affrontato con molta
angoscia
io ho avuto voce solo per lasciare i
bambini mio marito la mia mamma la mia
famiglia
solo per loro non per me io ho avuto
tutto e ringrazio dio per tutto quello
che mi ha dato questo messaggio non so
se fosse vivo tra pensateci perché è
molto importante in prison a pensarci
quanto sia tempo per pensarci non ho
tanta voglia di andarmene quegli secondo
me pozzo però da qualche pagina lì
qualche giornale quale notizia quello
che si tura bizzarra verrà fuori
non vi lascio dai un abbraccio grande a
tutti
non ho molto da aggiungere volevo che
ruzzola se fino a qui che che arrivasse
anche a voi vi saluto con una frase a
vent'anni si tenta la poesia 50 si pensa
che bisognava insistere con permesso a
ennio flaiano
io insisto spero anche voi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no